cuz I repeat I wanted it to be clear you liar that you didn't
answer my question. I asked you a specific question and you obuscated.
You went on this rant that wasn't connected. You didn't answer
my yes or no question. Doobie, you're a liar. You're just a liar.
You can go away now. Bye. I asked you a very specific question.
I interrupted you because you weren't answering that question.
You continued to assure me that you were about to answer that
question and then you lied to my face. Get the out of here. Get
the out. I've never seen Wick this fired up about anything except
anti-semitism.
So, I'm going to read maybe the first paragraph of the Wick Duby.
Okay, we'll read the thesis of this without reading into it too
much and then we'll go to Wick Doobie. So, basically Doobie's
arguing that this article is not really all that anti-semitic.
So, inif
is the name of the blog.
In
seems a little on the nose to begin with. Okay, seems a little
on the nose to begin with, but yes, all Jews, all Jews must kill
Zionism within Judaism.
I've come to have tremendous disdain for my people. The evil
we have wrought and the demons we have become. Our craven hypocrisy,
our Holocaust handringing, our hand ringing, eh, our selfish
disassociation,
our bottomless, our bottomless both sidesing, our catatonic inaction,
our feeble sign waving, our condescending condemnations, our
wallowing victim complex, our self-indulgent betrayals, our brazen
self-centerness, our exploitative careerism, our blood and soil
racism, our liberal cowardice, our mountains of empty platitudes
amongst mountains of Palestinian corpses that we annihilated
in cold blood. Israel has likely killed hundreds of thousands
of people in two and a half years of non-stop bombardment, executions,
and engineered starvation in Gaza. How much more? It's a long
article. I'm not going to do the whole article. I'm going to
get into the actual show. So, kind of set the stage for us here.
Uh, you called in last week and wanted to talk about the article
and you said it wasn't anti-semitic. Um, give us give us your
thoughts then. >> Well, first off, can you define anti-semitism?
Um, like how do when you say anti-mitism, you think it's anti-semitic?
Like what do you mean? Anti-semitism is discrimination, prejudice,
hostility or violence against Jews as Jews or institutions as
Jews. And there are several guidelines that it goes through,
right? Like so you can criticize or oppose Zionism or Israeli
policies harshly, that is not anti-Semitic according to this
definition. But if you essentialize or make sweeping negative
generalizations about as a group or hold collectively responsible
for Israeli actions, that is anti-semitic. So that's the definition
I use. If I were to say that >> we're good >> uh
all Catholics have a responsibility to target or to tackle the
systemic abuse that was happening in Catholic church which was
a very common thing and if they didn't they were told be like
implicit because their silence was complicity very similar thing
happens with Muslims after a terrorist attack right Muslim leaders
are called to to speak out against it to to condemn it yada yada
and if they don't um this is taking this complicity in some way
right so I think that this kind of like um uh demand for some
sense of like collective responsibility for a political ideology
or the actions uh that that arise because of a political ideology.
This isn't really attacking the group for being the group or
attacking um you know something inherent about the group itself
but it's more more there's an issue with it's more that hey there
is an issue within this within your community and because you
are part of this community you have a responsibility to tackle
that issue like I think that is what she's doing and I think
that the way that the the framing of um this holding collectively
responsible thing I think that if they were to just hold to to
those words themselves it' be a double standard that we don't
divide other communities which would also be >> so you
wouldn't consider just just to be clear like so let's use the
terrorism example that you brought up with the Muslim community
and things like that You wouldn't think uh it to be Islamophobic
or anti-Muslim
to demand that every Muslim in a community like say Dearborn
Michigan for example um condemn the actions of a terrorist group
across the world like so uh say uh the Houthies do something
horrific right or Hezblah does something horrific kills a bunch
of US Marines something like that and uh people go around to
random >> I think all so he just used the Houthies. I think
it would have to be
>> oh, could you even get I don't even know that you could
get this with Muslims.
Like, you would need a thing happening with Muslims that was
under a microscope for the world that have been used as a political
football for a very long time where one of the groups immediately
like after long periods of being accused of stuff sort of leaned
into every single negative stereotype and then it's like just
show that you're not you're not okay with that. like basically
disavow that like I I do think there's something to policing
your own and it's not like you have to police your own because
some Muslim in the Middle East like did a bombing somewhere you
police your own like after 9/11
I think it would just be a good idea if you were like Arab to
go like obviously I love you know America if you live in America
I totally disavow that that's crazy that's like insane I think
it's awful and you don't say but admit that it's like fun foundational
to being Arab like I'm never going to go admit that the war crimes
of Israel are foundational to being
that's that's insane. That's an insane thing to expect of people,
right? And when you say collective responsibility, I think it
has to be collective responsibility in
decrying bad action, not not collective responsibility as in
I want to do something to hurt people or get retribution and
I'm going to find somebody I can hold responsible who is not
directly responsible in any way, >> obviously. So, some
caveats. a bunch of US Marines, something like that. And uh people
go around to random uh Muslims in Dearborn, Michigan and demand
that they take a stand on this, right? You don't see any problem
with that? You don't think that would be Islamophobic? I I do.
I think that would be very uh Islamophobic. I think that would
be very anti-Muslim. I think that would be bigoted in a real
way. Um some guy in Dearborn, Michigan has nothing to do with
Hezbollah or the Houthies. They have no real connection to them.
They happen to share a religion, right? They happen maybe even
to be from the same region.
But that doesn't give us the right to demand that someone who
has no no real connection
apologize or be held responsible for or even condemn, right?
They would be just they would be justified in telling anyone
who told told them that they needed to condemn the actions of
a group they're not connected to to off. Do you disagree with
that? >> Yeah. I think that this is a misunderstanding
of the Houthies even. Right. So the Houthies aren't aren't committing
terrorism quote unquote. I don't I don't think most of the disturbance
is actually um because of Islam they militia group in a region
of the world that is acting for political reasons not because
of Islam right they have regional interest that they're they're
fighting for and defending right >> they say that >> well
hold on like Pete Hex says that we're fighting this war for God
is that >> no it's not true right so the so the United
States is not fighting a war for Christianity even if Pete Hex
says so >> I understand that which is why it would be weird
to demand a Christian who's
in South America to condemn right? What Pete Hexath claims he's
doing in the name of God,
>> even though they're both Christian, even I don't I don't
know if I'd actually call Pexath an actual Christian, but that's
another debate, right? Um, but
>> you would understand how it would be problematic. It
would be bad. It would be bigoted to demand all Christians everywhere
condemn that something that is done in their name, but they have
no connection to. >> No, I think they should. I think you
should encourage Christians to condemn it. if their religion
is being used to justify atrocities, I I think people who hold
this religion are responsible in some way for for calling it
out and cutting that that rod out of their community. I would
say the same about Christian nationalism, right? So, if there
are evangelical churches um where Christian nationalism is a
problem and it's and it's a massive issue growing in Christian
communities in the US, I think it is a responsibility of these
communities to police themselves and say, "Hey, we are not part
of this movement and this movement is not Christianity." I think
it's totally fine to to say this and I don't think it's bigoted
in any way. I I think it's I think in inter community uh critique
I'm sorry intra community critique is totally normal. It's something
that happens across all other communities. I really don't understand
why we'd have a specific carve out for religion or for uh for
in this case. >> So I think that intra community critique
can be done in ways that are perfectly fine and perfectly valid.
I don't necessarily as a concept for >> like if I was right
if I was to critique Mormonism or streamers right we'll use streamers
as a group right I can call like I think streamers have been
um very uh
negative in how they deal with the mentally ill right I think
that they use them for clicks for views all these things I think
they exploit them in many ways I think that streamers as a whole
>> kind of kind of do this but but it would be wrong of
me to then hold an individual streamer who has not done this
responsible in any way, shape or form to demand that they renounce
this kind of behavior. It would be putting a burden on them that
they do not deserve and do not share because they haven't engaged
in that behavior. They haven't done it. And I I'm against collective
punishment as a whole. And I think that what this article is
calling for in a very real way is a collective punishment to
as a whole to Judaism.
Disavowing killing kids is anti-semitic.
asking people to disavow killing kids is a punishment. I can't
believe you you'd collectively punish by asking them to disavow
the killing of men, women, and children in Gaza, civilians in
Gaza. I can't believe this. It's absolutely
Dude, dude,
I'm sorry. This is why Oh, there's so many things so many things
in my head right now. It has, you can go through the quotes if
you like, but it talks several times about how if uh if a wants
the target to be off their back, they have to uh enthusiastically
support the Alcasim brigades to uh praise the glory and miracle
of October 7th things.
Wait, does it really say that?
Genuine anti-Zionist unwaveringly unwaveringly support the total
eradication of Israel and the greater Satan America. full land
back without a speck of Zionist or Euroamerican imperial/settler
colonial control. This includes supporting and removing fellow
Jeans from Palestine while ensuring they don't do harm where
they go/ further displace indigenous peoples elsewhere and open
reverent support for Palestine's armed resistant resistance.
Gaza's mujahedin are at the heart of the struggle currently spearheaded
by Hamas's Alkasam brigades who executed the miraculous Alaka
flood on October 7th, 2023. An operation that genuine anti-inist
unequivocally recognized as one of the most prolific anti-colonial
operations in history.
Okay, this first is pretty insane.
Yes, all anti-semitic.
H core idea not anti-Semitic. I I don't even know if I'd say
this is I do I want to say this is anti-semitic. I think it's
like anti-human
in a way that like I understand what they're trying to say. Oh,
all settlers if you live in a settler colonial nation, you're
like doing something. This is probably pushing it to an extreme.
Like I just can't I I just can't wrap my head around.
It's It's funny, but I just can't in my head. I remember from
Queen's stream that's a lie. Oh, I'm watching this. I'm reading
this. There is I understand what they're saying. I'm not sure
I would say it's anti-Semitic. And Wick got it wrong a little
bit, right? Oh, you have to praise all of these things. I don't
know. Is it saying you have to be a genuine anti-ionist
and love all of these things or is it saying you just need to
call out Israel? >> So white people, for example, when
Obama said that all white people have a responsibility to tackle
racism. When Biden said that racism is a white man's problem,
right? I don't think they're like they're like anti statements
to >> No, that's silly.
There were facially bigoted statements today. To say that all
white men carry the burden of racism is something that we have
as a society largely begun to reject. We adopted it because we're
crazy for some reasons and we wanted to overlook that bigot bigotry.
But it is a form of bigotry. The vicious propagandists and funders,
the militarized, soldiers, settlers, modern Judaism reflects
terrorism, slaughter, blood, sadism, and organ theft out well
in and animate the age of totalitarian Judaism. This is on its
face an essentializing statement that we would not apply to any
other group or if it is applied to any other group, we would
absolutely call it out for being bigoted and racist and essentializing.
So for example, if I said that if Biden had said we whites are
the fascistic overlords of vicious propagandism funders and militarized
soldier colonial settlers, right? Modern whites. There's only
one white ethnostate and that ethnostate was doing some crazy.
I unfortunately
you're in a unique situation there too that you have to deal
with and you could reckon with that or not. You don't want to
reckon with that. That's your problem I guess. Okay. But you
have in the name of your ethnicity, religion, an ethnostate that
is perpetrating like horrific war crimes on people
and probably calling that out is a little bit that's a little
important. I think that's important, man. To reflect terror,
slaughter, blood, sadism, organ theft. Yeah, that would be racist
to say that would be super racist. >> Okay, so first off,
we are attacking right now is for the harshness of the critique,
right? Not the the the uh the structure of the critique itself.
So, I agree that it's harsh. A lot of her language is very inflammatory,
very bombastic. I wouldn't use some of the language she uses.
That doesn't make it anti-semitic. that doesn't make it look
like bigoted. Um seems to me is that hold on. So what she's actually
doing in this article is identifying an issue within her own
community and saying we need we are not doing enough to fight
this issue. Um and because we're not doing enough, we are complicit.
Which is again the same structure that was used to say that all
men have a responsibility to fight culture, for example. All
white all white people have a responsibility to fight racism.
All Catholics have responsibility to fight systemic abuse in
the Catholic Church. All Muslims have a responsibility to to
attack terrorist ideologies in their communities or jihadis in
their communities. Like this is very similar to all these other
I mean prophets Jewish prophets were extremely critical of their
community in way more inflammatory language than she used. Would
you say that they're anti-semitic because they call their community
vipers? They called they called Israel of a community of vipers.
Vipers the problem here is is is the trick you're doing here
where you try to kind of like jump from this is just harsh critique
and I think you jump over the other step that they are doing.
They aren't just using harsh words to identify people who have
engaged in behaviors that they find reprehensible. They are saying
that all Jews are not only responsible to call Hold on. Okay,
hold on. Hold on. We do need to look at this part, too. There
is an immoral of morality in sight. Palestine is an anti-colonial
and decolonial liberation struggle in which we are the fascistic
overlords, the vicious propagandists and funders, the militarized
soldier settlers, demolishing and stealing homes, igniting Westb
prims, and executing children on mass. Zionists will say this
evokes anti-semitic tropes. We don't care. Your words fall entirely
flat as in Israel celebrate Purum by cheering on bombings like
the murder of 165 school girls and staff killed by USIsraeli
air strikes on Iran. The truth of terrorism is already seared
into Palestinian land, jaggedly branded and carved into Palestinian
skin with swastikas of David.
Now dwell in the animate uh Jews now dwell in and animate the
age of totalitarian Judaism. I don't want to hear about anti-semitism
or victimhood ever again. Yeah, this is not unfortunately. While
I understand the colorful language is very upsetting to people,
I do not think this paragraph is anti-semitic either. Fortunately,
um there the other one about Alcasm and Ala flood. I would maybe
give you anti-semitic.
This one, no, I think this one's actually fairly accurate. You
don't like it, but it is fairly accurate. And that's what this
person is upset about. I think Doobie is more correct on this
one than other than
>> is is is the trick you're doing here where you try to
kind of like jump from this is just harsh critique and I think
you jump over the other step that they are doing. They aren't
just using harsh words to identify people who have engaged in
behaviors that they find reprehensible. They are saying that
all are not only responsible to call this out but responsible
for it. And there's a substantive difference saying you have
a responsibility as a member of a group to condemn X Y or Z.
There's problems with that. I have problems with that. But she
goes further than that and she's not only says not not only do
you have a responsibility to call this out, but you're guilty
of this. You're responsible for this and you deserve to pay for
this. >> Do you think it was wrong to impose denification
on Germans after World War >> No, I don't think it was
wrong to impose >> that hold all Germans collectively responsible
for Nazism. >> I think that if they were if they were
like shooting people who hadn't done anything, then that's a
problem, right? or if they were calling on the death of people
or to imprison people in Germany who had not engaged in any of
the Nazi rhetoric, who had not participated in any Nazi rhetoric
because well, let me ask you this. >> Wait, he just totally
Wait, you just totally got Wick just tripped all the way over
himself right there, dude. He >> further than that. What
the he not only says not not only do you have a responsibility
to call this out, but you're guilty of this. You're responsible
for this and you deserve to pay for this. >> Do you think
it was wrong to impose deification on Germans after World War
II? No, I don't think it was wrong to >> Why didn't that
hold all Germans collectively responsible for Nazism? >> I
think that if they were if they were like shooting people who
hadn't done anything, then that's a problem, right? Or if they
were calling on the death of people or to imprison people in
Germany who had not engaged in any of the >> Where is she
doing that? Where is she calling on
jail prison? No, I don't see I don't see anywhere where she's
doing that. I don't see that. the Nazi rhetoric would not participate
in Nazi rhetoric because well let me ask >> Germans were
responsible for the Nazis. Yeah. Well, no. This the whole thing
is like basically there can be like a a rot that's so pervasive
it needs the the society to call it out. The society isn't willing
to engage in the in the internal critique then it's like too
pervasive. It's too protected. That rot can't be fixed
without people calling out Zionism and the what's happened in
Israel. Israel can never be fixed. There will never be something
that works >> What she's talking about isn't Israel itself.
She's talking about Zionism, the the ideology of Zionism. And
if you were to look at a uh I think there have been polls on
this and like over like 90% of people consider themselves Zionist
or consider that or support the existence of a state, right?
So she's attacking that, right? Not just the state of Israel,
but that ideology that she believes has uh taken over her community.
Right. So so if every if uh German Americans were supporting
Nazis, then it would make sense to to say that they have a responsibility
to condemn Nazism. Right. If there was >> Yes. Right. Right.
Right? Because the polling in America shows the support for Zionism
in the state of Israel is massive. So it's a little different
if you had a German if you had like a German enclave where they
openly supported Germany during the war and well during the war
with Europe maybe even before America declared war on them or
something. If you had that that coalition there, yeah, that would
be a thing
identifying as supporting Hitler then. Yes. But but here's here's
a problem with what you just said though, right? You you mentioned
that 90% or whatever percentage I think you used, I think it
was 90%, support the existence of a state. That does not necessarily
imply support for what Israel is doing or even support for Israel
where it's at and how it exists now. Right? I can support a state
and also say well I think Israel is an ethnost state. I think
what they're doing >> okay hold on give me a second. There
is something be in my house. I have to see what it is. Give me
a sec. >> Is horrific and they probably should be disbanded.
You can believe both things. These are not contradictory. Again,
she's doing the thing where she conflates that anyone who's even
neutral towards Israel or even condemned it but doesn't praise
the murders that have been engaged against it is a Zionist. She
calls you a Zionist, Dubie. >> Yeah. So, I don't think
that she believes there were murders on October 7th. So, I read
some of her other work. It seems like she doesn't believe. She
thinks that's like the narrative pushed by Israel. And I think
there's some I think there's some strong evidence that that did
happen. Um, I did believe that there were of course, but I think
it's also true that there were opportunists and liars who um
exploited that fact and exaggerated that fact to make money or
to push like an like an anti-Palestinian narrative. So, she doesn't
believe that those things happened. I disagree with her. I think
some of that did happen. I don't think there's like masters,
but absolutely some people were raped.
>> What would you call someone who denied the Holocaust?
Who denied that were being killed in camps in the Holocaust?
What would you call that person? >> I think there's far
far more evidence that the Holocaust happened there were like
mass on October 7th, which is the narrative that she is combating.
>> Okay. I think that you're correct technically that yes,
there is more evidence on the Holocaust. Yes, that is true. But
I think that there is compelling and damning evidence about what
Hamas did on October 7th. There's video evidence that we have
from multiple sources. Hamas video themselves doing these things.
We have this evidence. We It's strong. The UN has come out with
reports detailing this evidence and we can quibble on some of
the details here and there. But I think that someone who still
denies that uh Hamas killed in people on October 7th, that in
and of itself is anti-Semitic in a big way. >> Yeah. Why?
Using the definition that you brought up earlier.
>> Yeah. I'm going to refer to the definition we used earlier.
Right. The saying they need to be punished for their actions.
It's a way to hold them accountable and to deny any kind of any
there's no wrong you can do against that group. And if you do
it wrong against that group, we're going to cover it up for you.
We're going to deny that ever happened. It's anti-semitic in
nature. Do you not understand that? >> No. I think they
Okay, now it's a German saying
the Zionist insist that hating Israel is tantamount to hating
Jews. Then in the same breath demand same breath demand that
we that people do not conflate Israel with Jews. When I remark
to Jews that we are all responsible for ending Zionism and the
ongoing Palestinian genocide, I usually hear not all Jews say
Zionists not Jews. There are actually more Christian Zionist
than ones. Well, I'm speaking to right now people who support
fascist Zionism in lock step across every institution or community.
organized formations across the entire community to keep the
colony humming through dieh hard and consistent commitment propaganda
money or sorry propaganda money and resources considering strengthening
and defending Israel to not only be a mitzvah but part of their
duty towards the people and extension of their identity mind
you people are currently operating a string of torture and dungeons
in Palestine and pummeling Lebanon and Iran with air strikes
yeah I'm sorry I'm by the way not going to say this is anti-semitic
because it is a person doing it and they are disgusted by these
actions there is a different element when it is somebody inside
of that community saying we collectively are responsible for
this thing and I want my like the people with me to actually
agree and and do their best to try to break this thing down and
stop playing into like collective identity in a way that actually
perpetuates harm in the world.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> But you were pretending that she
doesn't actually believe that these things didn't happen and
she's only saying that they didn't happen because she hates shoes.
I think she actually doesn't believe it that happened. And again,
I think there's very strong evidence that at least the extreme
claims of like mass um on October 7th, we're not sure. Maybe
ahead of baby singing. Not true. Right. So, it is true that there
were lives floating around early on and still >> Uh oh,
Wick. Wick's not going to Wick's dude. You hear that? There's
the internal monologue for Wick just doing the heavy breathing.
>> There were people going around giving like uh like speeches
to huge crowds of people that were later supposed to totally
lied about their involvement and what they did and who they saved
and all those kinds of [__] So, I think it's one
of the reason to be like uh suspicious of that narrative. And
if she believes that the narrative is totally made up, either
because she hasn't seen enough evidence or because she's seen
evidence of people lying about this, I I don't think it's anti-semitic.
>> I do not think that she would accept any evidence. And
the reason I don't think that is because I think she is anti-semitic.
And the reason I think she is anti-semitic is because she's essentializing
all holding them all >> Isn't this the only loner box agreement
debate that actually happened? And lonerbox just basically conceded
that if you think mass means like mass systemic like top down
orders you need to go and rape use rape as a weapon of war then
no mass didn't occur.
That's what Doobie is saying which we >> She's praising
Hamas the glorious Alcasim brigade right and Hamas to be clear
has called for the death of all right all of them right globally.
Um >> uh hold on that's not >> I'll read you some
quotes. >> No you're going to go back like the 80s or something
but >> from 2019. >> Okay. Yeah. Yeah, read the from
2019 because I know that recently um I think even like uh before
million Palestinians abroad really quickly before and after let
me finish with my let me finish what I think before and after
after October 7th there were like Hamas spokespeople saying that
um that their their fight is not with it is with Israel. It was
with the Zionist entity. >> Well, here's what Fafi Hammad
the senior Hamas official uh said in 2019. He said you 7 million
Palestinians abroad there are everywhere. We must attack every
Jew on planet earth. That's all of them. We must slaughter and
kill them. >> Yeah. That do you think? Do you think anyone's
denying that anti-semitism exists, Wick?
No. Anti-semitism has never been a thing, Wick. Also, I'm going
to use a bunch of things where I say Nazis are bad and the Holocaust
was disgusting, but I don't think anti-semitism exists.
What does he think he's proving here? Yeah, there's anti-semmites
out there. I'm sure there are anti-semites who want all attacked
everywhere in the world for anything Israel's ever done. That's
not me. That's not I don't think that's this
I've not seen that anywhere else. them with Allah's help. We
will die while exploding and cutting the necks and legs off the
we will lacerate them and tear them to pieces again on planet
Earth.
>> Okay, I believe that this man wants to
>> Can I I just wish we I wish Dubie would do some about
it and just go you understand that you've never shown this level
of passion for like what's happening in Lebanon actively right
now, right? Like you don't have this level of passion, but somebody's
saying some
literally somebody getting quot you you're quoting someone. So
this person said, "Glory to the Alcasm brigades."
And so you quote one specific Hamas guy
and now after now you've somehow presented that's an argument.
It's not. I don't know what to tell you.
I dude >> their official position before and after October
7th uh is that their fight is with Israel, not >> Has been
their state of position for years again before and after. >> I
need my I need my I need my tweet. I need my my Vos clip. I need
my Vos clip. Unfortunately, there's just going to be no limit
to how much we could reuse this clip. This clip is infinitely
reusable. >> The unambiguous position of the Democrat >> of
Wick TV >> party and the Republican party right now is
that they expect their voters to choose between the feelings
of people and the future of the United States.
>> The future of Arabs in the region or the feelings of
people? Which one? Which one, guys? Well, which chooses the feelings
of people every single time? >> This is a fact. There is
no room for argument on this.
>> Critique the actions of Israel. Nah, some dude said
everywhere need to be attacked.
What the are you talking about, Dwey? This random guy said everybody
needs to be attack. You hear him like he's grinding his teeth
while he's yelling.
>> I agree with that. This guy um wants to kill all Jews.
>> That that is that is their stated goal. Hamas's stated
goal is to kill all the >> Okay, that is this man official
language for propaganda purposes. >> I believe they've
updated that. But >> but that is what they believe and
that is what they have said over and over and over again. I believe
they've updated that to not be about broadly in a future leadership
has said this. I'm going to quote you another one from 2023.
Uh this is Gazi Hammad of Hamas political official and he says
repeat and he vowed repeatedly to annihilate Israel and continue
October 7th style attacks time and time again until Israel is
annihilated in 2012. She Yeah, that's what Dubie said. They really
hate Israel. Yep.
Is that anti-Semitic? Wig, hold on. Wig, was that anti-Semitic?
Was that anti-Semitic?
Let's play the same game for Israeli statements. Oh, no. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You don't want to
do that. You don't want to You don't want to do that. >> Ahmad
Bar says, "Oh Allah, destroy the Jews and their supporters. Oh
Allah, count them one by one and kill them all without leaving
a single one. The they're anti."
Okay, I would say also that guy maybe he means worldwide. I well
I mean one of them said supporters as well but you have to understand
I think a lot of people in the region don't do the same differentiation
and they don't meet people from outside like literally all the
in that region are in one place it's synonymous for them
right
unless there's there are people who say you know worldwide the
one guy said worldwide attack everywhere they're everywhere attack
them everywhere right
is actually like like calling for something evil >> because
I support Israel even though I don't, right? I just don't want
to see it wiped off the face of the earth, right? Um because
I support Israel under that framing does not mean I support every
single law they pass or what they do in Gaza. >> What do
you mean you support Israel? Like what does that mean? >> Okay.
I think that the people of Israel have the right to self-determination
and should have the right to self-determination. And that shouldn't
>> all of Israel or
like between
all people between Jordan, Syria, Lebanon, Egypt, and
I think that gets everything right, that those people have the
right to self-determination. How how should we split that self-determination
up? They shouldn't be forcibly excised from the area, nor should
they be killed. I think Israel has a right uh quote unquote to
exist. Um, I don't like what it's doing in Gaza. I condemn it.
I don't like how it's conducted itself during this war. I don't
like how it's conducted itself prior to the war in many cases.
But this isn't a conversation about what I Okay, you don't like
it. What don't you like?
Please, please, Dubie has the opportunity. What don't you like
about what's happened in Gaza?
What What happened in Gaza since the war? What has happened?
What is your understanding of what's happened in Gaza since the
war started
support or don't support about Israel? This is a conversation
where we are wondering if someone who again has no support for
Israel, has no connection to Israel, who happens to be in California
has any responsibility for what Israel does or does not do. This
article says that they do bear >> things started beeping
again. I'mma lose it. I'mma lose it. responsibility and they
are
a target.
Okay, I language essentializ
someone across the globe on someone who has no connection and
no like they have no say in this, right? They have no responsibility
here. They should not be condemned for it. They should they are
not guilty. They have not done anything. >> Okay, but this
isn't true because she explicitly lays out a way to escape this
criticism work
to commit to anti-inism and to fight anti-inism with your with
your full chest, right? not just be tapped about it but to attack
the institution of Zionism within community to attack to yeah
go for it >> show genuine anti-Zionist unwaverly support
the total eradication of Israel and the greater Satan America
the full land back without a speck of Zionist or Euroamerican
imperialist colonial control this includes supporting removing
fellow Jews from Palestine while ensuring they don't do harm
where they go further displace indigenous peoples elsewhere so
not only is she saying that if unless you want to destroy Israel
destroy America ethnically cleanse the Jews from Palestine which
by she means all of Israel, right? Gaza, West Bank, and Israel
proper, right? And and and that these Jews are so dangerous that
you have to be careful where you put them because they're going
to just do it again because they're like that, right? That's
what she's saying. >> She doesn't say are like that. >> That
is obviously of the statement. >> No, the implication is
that if they leave the area, she doesn't want there to be a new
Israel made, a new ethnosate imposed on some other group of people.
Right? That is what she's saying. She's not saying that you just
do this to people. She's saying we've uh our community has adopted
and lashed on to or I think she said that the ide ideology has
lashed on to the community and we are not doing enough to fight
this ideology which is toxic and poisonous and uh genocidal and
racist and she thinks that every school has a responsibility
to fight this thing and if you do fight this thing she's your
ally. She's I'm sure she doesn't think that she um is like uh
is unsalvageable and she and she just needs to be killed or whatever
the [__] she believes that there are others like
her who are already fighting this evil right and she's calling
on all to fight this evil in the way that a Christian pastor
might call on all Christians to fight Christian nationalism or
a German leader might call all Germans to fight Nazism. It's
the ideology she's attacking and she believes that this ideology
is dominating her community and every institution in her community.
>> But the way she is attacking the ideology is to demand
that people who are unconnected to that ideology who have no
responsibility for that ideology be held responsible for that.
>> You think
it can be. Yes. If you are saying that black people right or
that all white people I should say all white people need to it's
step aside or to um bear a burden because of something they did
not do. That's a little bit big. >> That is that is literally
DEI. It's the idea that because white people have white privilege,
which I'm sure you also think is bigoted, I guess, because white
privilege exists within the white community, um, then all all
white people have a are generalized and essentialized quote unquote,
and that they are treated differently in hiring practices. That
is DEI. That is exactly what you're saying. So, you believe that
it is you believe that the concept of white privilege it
>> it is just because the essentialization is positive
in some case or negative in another case, it's still centralization.
the concept of white privilege
equivalent things >> if if you look at the context of that
wick she's talking not she shouldn't say that they're going to
be killed
>> okay just read it
on the back the context remember quickly is like Nermberg is
like hey you're supporting political ideology you need to held
held responsible for supporting this political ideology >> okay
so I'm going to read quick really quickly and this is very similar
I think to the way that you and Destiny and others talk about
MAGA right how they need to be held responsible for supporting
Trump it's the exact same >> hold another toxic ideology
one second one second toxic ideology that you think the Republican
party itself
cut out of their party. >> Wick is going to keep Wick is
going to continue spiraling cuz he doesn't understand. He's going
to GO BUT IT'S IN ANOTHER COUNTRY. You need to continue driving
back to the vast majority of people in America are Zionists.
They are overt Zionists. And what she's calling out is this this
phenomenon that it's not just America. I'm sure maybe she might
not even be American. She's calling out this phenomenon
that because of some collective like victim complex, people will
support uh Israel through monstrous undertakings. Like they they
will support monstrous action because they think that Israel
needs to exist for them to fall back to and survive.
And they need to like kill that idea within their brain. like,
hey, we either have to buy into the new world or go all in on
killing everybody in the Middle East, but don't pretend you could
sit in the middle.
Sitting in the middle is disgusting.
>> I want you to go back and I want you to watch the discussions
between me and Destiny on what we should do about MAGA. And I
guarantee you that we have a very different opinion. I argue,
in fact, that not all MAGA or Trump voters should be held responsible
and not even all Republican politicians should be held responsible
for the actions of Trump. I explicitly argue this. So for you
to say that I my position is that we should essentialize and
hold them responsible and that's again forgetting that MAGA in
and of itself is something you buy into. It's not something you're
born into MAGA. So there's differences there. But you're just
wrong on its face. So you're wrong to compare the two. And you're
also wrong about my position here. And let me go ahead. Let me
let me read the context of this target on the back thing. Okay.
Says uh many will say the argument I put forth unfairly puts
a target on people's backs. You're still missing the point. We
support genocidal Zionism across the entirety of our faith. We
put the target on ourselves and can take it off by ourselves
by relinquishing genocidal Zionism and asserting principled anti-Zionism.
But more fundamentally, we aren't the victims targeted by Zionism.
We are the perpetrators of it. The real targets are those material
placed on Palestinians by Israelis. This is again essententralizing
language. She's saying support genocidal Zionism across the entirety
of our faith. And that's just not true. >> Wig, what does
essentializing mean to >> Essentializing is when you say
all are X or all blacks are or Y or all whites are Z. That's
essentializing. You're taking a group and you're saying every
member of that group is the same. They're essentially the same.
>> Okay. So, if I were to say that um uh Democrats hold
liberal values, right? Do you think that'd be essentializing?
>> Can you say that one more time? >> Democrats hold
liberal values? >> No. But you have to hold liberal values
to be a democrat. It's not you're not it's not an ethnicity.
And these are different things. It's an ideology that you buy
into. If I said all Zionists believe in Zionism, then yes, that
would be correct. But if I said all of a certain ethnicity believed
in Zionism, that would be incorrect. You understand the difference?
>> Wick. Okay. No, because the vast majority I'm getting
there. because a vast majority of are Zionists and and in fact
what you read out she specifically says that if you want to they
want to take the target off their backs and again she's talking
like in the context of like Nber Nurberg trials that they need
to reject Zinism they need to relinquish sinism and and adopt
uh principal anti-inism right so she's specifically saying hey
this isn't inherent to who are they can change my community can
change and can be better this is how to be better so this is
not we are evil because we're it's again the entire push of the
article is this toxic evil ideology has attached to our community
and all of our institutions are in support of it and like 90
something% of Jews are in support of this thing and it's our
responsibility to cut that evil So this this is her specifically
saying that there is a way out because they're not intrinsically
evil because this is not how our community should be or has been.
In fact, she talks about like historically and how they've attacked
exactly this kind of concept and exactly this kind of evil. Right?
So she is not saying that the community is evil because of their
she has adopted an evil ideology and she wants them to kick it
out. >> Okay, I'm going to read you
is it is Wick is literally just reading and not listening. Wick
is reading and not listening at all.
This is crazy. Like Dubie just laid it all out.
How? What do you even disagree? Just disagree with what Dubbie
said there. Disagree with some element of what he's saying there.
But Wick is going to not engage directly with Dubby's argument.
He is going to just reset and restate some thing, some principal
thing. Instead of actually like reading or sorry, listening to
the argument and
>> Uh I have come to have tremendous disdain for my people,
the evil we have wrought and the demons we have become. Our craven
hypocrisy, our holocaust hand ringing, our selfish dissociation,
both sides in catatonic inaction, feeble sign waving, condescending
condemnations, walling victim complex, self-indulgent betrayals,
brazen self-centerness, self-centeredness, exploitative careerism,
blood and soil racism, liberal cowardice, empty platitudes amidst
mountains of Palestinian corpses. Again, she's making no distinction
between Zionists right in her community or her people and her
pe in the Judaism as a whole, calling them demons that they have
become. >> So, dude, like this is here's the thing. Let's
let's make up um
do we have to make up an ethnicity?
Let's say we have the ethnicity of blah blah blah blah. Do we
have blah blah blah blah ethnicity? Okay. Let's say there's an
ethnostate of people of that ethnicity. I'm not going to do that.
Um I call them Zulus. So there's a nation of Zulus, an ethnostate
of Zulus. Only one only one ethnostate of Zulus. And then in
America, Zulus believe in one thing that is not intrinsic. But
the ethnostate constantly does and practices
In America, 95% of people also support
You think it's weird for one for a Zulu to write an article and
go, "Guys, cannibalism isn't something we have to do. We should
stop cannibalism.
We should guys, isn't it up that we do cannibalism?" And it's
like, "Well, hold on. That's Zulu nation does cannibalism." Some
of us, like 5% of us in America, we don't do cannibalism. Why
would you Why would you centralize all of us, but it's like,
dude, every single person you talk to supports cannibalism. They're
all cannibals.
It's It's not like, okay, it's I understand the person who's
in that group, right, who understands that they're in that group
and they see it every day. They go, "Dude, we need to stop. Zulus
is what LTG calls Africans." Well, the Zulu tribe was an African
tribe, but I'm literally just thinking about I'm literally just
thinking about Civ. I'm literally just thinking about playing
Civ. I think you get to attack twice with Zulu soldiers in Civ
4. Civ 5, sorry. I'm just thinking about Zulu's
demons. That is an anti-semitic trope that when you say all responsible
for collectively for the actions of some that is classic anti-semitism.
It's something that she does again and again throughout the article.
She links you're he's literally just going to never ever listen
and continue repeating himself over and over again.
Yeah. No. Um,
the Zulus are not in
Civ 7. No. Oh, what's the guy's name? Why can't I remember his
name? Shaka.
Dude, Shaka is out of the game. That's crazy. Shaka's been in
like all of the Civ games. They took Shaka out. It was up
to the forces of evil. But Shaka kind of sucks cuz Shaka is always
like
going super hard. like he you hate seeing him in a game cuz he
always he always goes hard at you. He always just attacks. It's
kind of racist of the civ developers when you think about it.
His like aggressiveness is like maxed out,
right? And say again, not just Zionists, right? Not just people
in Israel, right? Not just Israel supporters, but all everywhere
because they happen to be born.
No, but that's not true because
don't have to say that she doesn't have to say that they're anti
that there's some gene or some something wrong
anti-semitic. She can if you are saying that every everywhere
has been indoctrinated into this they have no choice, right?
That is an anti-semitic thing to say. It's wrong and
>> Okay. So basically Wick's saying the reality is wrong
and it's anti-semitic to point it out.
Like if she said essentially all
essentially all to be correct but because she said all it's actually
totally invalid now when it is like if she said 90% 95%
a vanishingly small number of take the morally correct position
like what are what are we supposed to do again supporting the
existence of anite is exactly what she's talking about. She says
that that itself that in and of itself is enough to say that
you are supporting uh like ethnic hierarchy, you're supporting
genocide, you're supporting ethnic cleansing, you're supporting
um everything that we that the Holocaust taught us to to reject.
So Jews came out of the Holocaust and the work of the Holocaust
saying, "Hey, ethnic hierarchy is wrong and we cannot support
this. We apply the standard to South Africa. We apply the standard
to Myanmar. We apply the standard to Japan. But with Israel,
there's a big blind spot for some reason, right?" So she's applying
the standard consistently. And I think if she
>> really quickly no, can you show me an article tweet
that she has made?
The mercury from the tooth is leaking into his brain. I don't
know. >> So, isn't it interesting? Isn't it interesting
that she's only calling out one community? >> It's her
community. What are you talking >> Isn't it interesting
if she's if she is >> Isn't it interesting that she's only
calling out her community that she belongs to ethnically?
Not particularly, Wick. No, it's literally not particularly impressive
at
>> Oh, ethnostates. >> It's actually so It's so embarrassing.
I guarantee you if I go look around some of the places that I
know to be like pro-Israel in the space, they'll think Wick is
like cooking here. There will be people who totally think Wick
is cooking here. And I I don't even know how you resolve things
when people see things this differently. I really don't. Like
literally, Duby is just racist point blank. Dub is just racist
point blank. Wick. He ignores the existence of liberal Zionism,
which is a big part of Zionist in the US and Israel, and don't
support its actions. Wick is a liberal Zionist. Dude, dude. Dude.
I see a woman getting brutally in alley. Okay. This woman is
screaming for help and somebody starts walking over to go help
her. I stop them and go, "Whoa, I think she's consenting to that."
And I stop you to try to have a debate for hours about whether
or not she's consenting.
Am I not supporting the I'm literally blocking anybody? I'm trying
my best to distract people from it and allowing it to continue.
Why am I not a bad person? Somebody explain that to me. Like
that's the problem is you're trying to take this out and say
we could just have this conversation, but it's like one of these
sides is getting obliterated
over and over and over again. One one of the countries is continue
to do crimes to other countries now. They picked new targets
and all these people want to go, "Whoa."
Aren't you concerned that what you're saying might lead to a
little
I I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. It's >> It should be understood that the unambiguous
position of the Democratic party and the Republican party right
now is that they expect their voters to choose between the feelings
of people and the future of the United States. Um, this is a
fact. There is no room for argument on this. >> Every time.
Every time. Every time. Every time. >> Why isn't she calling
out other ethnostates? Wick, it is her community that is supporting
this ethnos that exists in her name. Like this is totally like
of course she's going to focus on that ethnostate. >> Like
that's totally reasonable. Wick. >> I don't think it is.
I think if you oppose ethnostates, you should oppose ethnostates.
But she >> she references other ethnostates she opposes
in the article about the ethnostate that would accept her. I
she does oppose them. She hasn't written an article cuz probably
just a random being like, "Hey, Japanese people,
you kind of [__] up. They probably wouldn't really
care." doesn't. She opposes one ethnostate and no other at all.
That's not true. >> Then show me evidence that that's not
>> Wait, you're making the claim. You need to show me evidence
that she supports other ethnates. >> Hold on. I can't I
can't prove you that she's never done something, right? I can't
do that. >> You're making the claim that she doesn't do
this with no there's no reason to believe this at all. >> There
is her community and the fact that I can find no evidence of
her doing it in any other case. >> Wait, she explicitly
calls like America like Satan talks about colonialism and imperialism
and how the West is like evil and like I'm I'm sure if we're
like ask her, she would say that she was all left with no states.
I don't I don't think in fact I think she references like a part
of South Africa in the article. I'm sure she doesn't support
the part of South Africa, right? So I think that you make
as a whole. You understand that? >> Why, right? Hold on.
>> You think that
I >> I mean she's she's literally saying ethnostates are
wrong and Wick is going, "Show me articles of her calling out
other ethnostates." Well, actually, she's calling out every ethnostate
when she says ethnostates are wrong. And then she focuses in
on is on Israel.
You would have to show some reason to believe that there's some
ethnostate she she supports outside of the collective group she's
identified and disavowed
someone do well let me just ask do you think that someone could
be neutral towards ethnostates but still be against apartheid
South Africa
>> um no >> you don't I disagree I know plenty of
people who are who don't just don't give a about Japan or other
ethnostates it's not a real big deal but they are against apartheid
South Africa because of the
>> dude hold on
wait which other ethnos state. Are they okay with the existence
of that ethnostate requiring ethnic cleansing and/or like mass
murder of other groups, other ethnic groups? Is there somebody
is does this person exist? Cuz which ethnos are they good with?
Where is Japan mass murdering people
to continue their ethnostate? Where are they mass expelling people
ma massively ethnically cleansing people to maintain their ethnostate?
Where has that happened?
and the crimes that were committed under >> because because
an ethnosate requires uh like again ethnic hierarchy and oppression
in some way to maintain itself. This has been the case in every
ethnos in history. So if you want to pretend that that's not
the case fine but like the reality is that if you if you just
don't give a [__] about ethnos generally and you
support the existence of of ethnos and you don't like say that
u people support ethnos should be called out then yeah you're
you are actually okay with an ethnic hierarchy existing which
is exactly the the less the opposite of the lesson that we took
from the holocaust. When people came out of the holocaust again
the the what we learned is extreme nationalism and ethnic nationalism
and ethnic hierarchies are unacceptable. The entire world condemned
this right. So you're rejecting that and saying that it's in
Israel's case it's okay to have this and and again you're you're
claiming
>> but I don't support Israel
but I don't like what happened in Gaza but I don't support what
happened in Lebanon.
I just think you're a little anti-Semitic.
>> Cool. The context in which I say that well first of
all I don't like ethnostates. I don't like that Israel is an
ethnostate. >> Hearing it again having to hear I don't
like what happened in Israel. I don't like what happened in Gaza.
I don't like what happened in Lebanon.
I just think Israel have a right to exist.
Might not be good, but is it better than the alternative? And
we have to ask, what would happen if Israel stopped being an
ethnostate? What would happen? And as I have researched this
and as I have seen, the most likely outcome of them just ceasing
to be an ethnostate is that they would all the in that region
would either be forcibly removed from that region or killed.
One of those two things would happen. >> Why do you think
this? >> Because there are a lot of groups that surround
Israel. >> I don't think, by the way, Dubie should say,
do you think we're saying it has to be it has to stop being like
an ethnostate in every way? The ethnic majority, the exact political
structure needs to change massively. where they're massively
outnumbered in that in that country tomorrow. Is that what you
think we're arguing for? Because that is the that is the straw
man that gets constructed, right? It's the straw man that gets
constructed again and again and again. Nobody is saying tear
down the walls in Gaza, open up the West Bank, give them all
a country, right? Nobody's saying any of this. So why are we
pretending that
have said that that's what they want to >> Wait, hold on.
>> I'm going to read you again from Hamas's charter. Right.
>> Okay. Irrelevant quick. You can >> Why is it irrelevant?
what the relevant
Okay, wait really quickly. You're talking about a political ideology,
a militant political ideology, a violent political ideology.
I agree. But you're talking about a political ideology. You can
have uh some kind of like immigration process say if you if you
believe in this ideology, you're not allowed in here. If you're
in our country and you're advocating for this political ideology,
you're not allowed. You can do that, right? You don't need to
say, "Oh, well, if we let the Arabs, they're going to kill the
Jews." Because that is what you're implying. >> I think
that it has happened in every other state in that region. There
are no more like the populations in the states in the Arab regions
surrounding that area don't exist anymore. Wait, aren't you applying
a collective standard right >> No, I'm not applying a collective
guilt right now. I am saying I would never hold an Arab who lives
in Brooklyn responsible for that. >> Yeah, but you're just
ask
the difference between me and this article, right? Is I don't
provide I don't apply a global guilt to a specific group for
the actions of something that happened across
these are different things and you keep trying to equate these
things, but they're not the same.
starts to become an argument when that group across the world
supports those actions, supports the state committing those actions.
That's the problem. That's the difference. You've pretended to
not understand this about a hundred times now. I don't even know
why you guys do debates. I actually don't know. you guys need
a moderator or something cuz like literally you've looped on
the same point a hundred times
and you have not engaged with the idea that if most of those
people a overwhelming majority of those people support the state
undertaking the genocidal actions then that is a problem and
asking them to say actually we've switched up. We no longer support
the state because of the genocidal actions. Because obviously
to do a genocidal act would mean or repeated repeatedly do genocidal
actions, repeatedly engage in ethnic cleansing, repeatedly engage
in war crimes. Obviously, after a massive track record is established
of these things happening over a three-year period,
you wouldn't want to support that state anymore. You go, actually,
you know what? Miss me with that. Miss me with that evil. >> Wait,
you're implying that Middle Eastern Arabs would kill all the
Israel if they got the chance. I am implying that the people
who are surrounding Jerusale not Jerusalem Israel right now have
said that that's what they that that's what they would do right
and that it has happened before in that area. So the most likely
outcome, right, if they got if they if that was before Israel
had one of the most advanced militaries in the world, are those
guy are those countries really coming at Israel super hard when
Israel's got nukes
there? Those countries are going to go and try to strike Israel,
try to blitz Israel. Really? Do we really think that's going
to be a thing?
>> They stopped vetting who came in, right, by and stopped
keeping it. >> It's like totally disconnected from the
current situation. majority state is that that's what would happen.
And again, I don't like ethnostates, but you have to you have
to consider what is the alternative. I don't see this
reasonable future. I don't see a path in a reasonable future
to any sort of one
>> It gets harder and harder the longer you let them continue
on this path. by the
Like surely
if 5 years ago peace was possible in some way or 10 years or
20 years ago, it's surely is not possible right now, right? After
what Israel's done in the region, but that's because of Israel's
actions, not because of like genocidal hatred of the people around
>> Non-ethnostate where people in that region still exist.
I don't see that >> Do black African-Americans deserve
an ethno state in the south?
Do black African-Americans deserve an ethnostate in the South?
No. >> Yeah. Wait, but they were persecuted and enslaved
lynched? Uh like why why wouldn't they get an ethnic state?
>> Hold on. Is that right now? Like you could have made
the argument. You could have made the argument post World War.
Post World War that they needed that, right? That they had to
have that you I might have depending, right? I'd have to research
it more, right, and look at the things more. But what was done
to to black people in the South? Like if they had had an ethnostate,
more of them would be alive today. >> No, I don't. >> You
don't think so?
No, because that would have allowed those two countries to ferment
aggression like ferment hatred for each other over a long period
of time, right? And if if they're all collectivized and it becomes
race against race, that becomes almost impossible to solve.
>> No, I think it's ridiculous. First off, >> dude,
that's what nobody understands that Ariel Chiron was the greatest
peacemaker. Okay,
I don't know how to run this. He allowed the mixing of the Palestinians
in the West Bank to create the conditions for them to love each
other. Okay. I don't know. I can't even I can't even with the
pigs, man. I'm sorry. I'm trying, but I can't. I can't I can't
do it. >> Okay. I I just disagree. Remember, if you went
to try to vote black man in the South, even this is post World
War II, not post World War II, post Civil War, right? Um they
would they would lynch you, they would kill you, they would rip
you, they would drive you, destroy you, right? And it happened
over and over and over again. So, yeah, maybe they should have
had some place where they could go where they warm up and protect
themselves. Maybe they should have had >> Okay. How many
people did that happen
>> Yeah. Like three I think 3 to 4,000 and like uh like
a quarter of them were white Republicans, right? Who were lynched
uh alongside the black people for like supporting the right to
vote. So I agree. Terrible. I agree. There's obviously systemic
immig uh systemic uh discrimination, racism, people being intimidated.
But that does not justify the creation of an ethnic state where
this this uh racial divide is going to be uh made permanent,
right? Uh seeing each other as like having like an ethnic hierarchy
and outsiders and insiders, us versus them. That would be in
>> What do you mean permanent? What do you mean permanent?
You think I'm calling for a forever ethnost state in Israel?
No. I think you would be working to a a time and a place where
they don't need it. But I am acknowledging the reality that at
this time in the year of our Lord 226 without it, it would be
a >> That's Wait, that's silly. So >> why you say
I think it's becoming less silly by the day, unfortunately. No,
like sorry. It's not going to be silly because Israel will always
be able to defend itself militarily against like the Arabs around
them. They've they've successfully defanged basically every one
of their peers in the region. Like they are not really under
threat at this point. It would have to you'd have to go years
and years into the future, right? Like there is no army that
could invade and that they wouldn't be able to just like totally
massacre. And that I think that's without
I I believe that to be the case without US support. With US support,
if the if the US were to just give a tiny little bit of security
guarantee to them still, they would be totally fine. >> Yeah.
Yeah. So, what would be the problem with Palestinians um in Gaza
and the West Bank getting access to full equal rights and asit
as Israeli citizens and those areas become parts of Israel? What
would be the issue with >> The issue is that they would
have as I understand it, I have to look at the the population
numbers again that
ethnicity would no longer be the majority in Israel and that
they would be able to be outvoted on things and there are enough
people in those regions that just want all out or dead that it
would be it would be to do that at this point. So I'm just saying
that like there are enough Jews
that want Israel to exist that if nobody starts talking about
this in America,
Israel like political Zionism in America will always exist.
No, YOU CAN'T SAY THAT. THAT'S THAT'S A
OKAY, hold on. I don't want to centralize now. What did you just
say about Palestinian Arabs in Israel if they were to bring in
the West Bank and Gaza? What was that you said? Oh, so many people
would want to kill them and they could get outvoted and it would
be a massacre.
>> Interesting point. >> Wow. Okay. So, you are making
a collective guilt thing. You're saying that all Palestinian
collective guilt. >> Yeah, it is. Wait. >> No. Because
I don't think that all Palestinians everywhere want this nor
are responsible. >> I'm talking about in West Bank and
Gaza. So, those Palestinians specifically in the West millions
of people westbra
if you wanted to say if you wanted to say that all in Israel
right have some responsibility for what Israel is doing. That
would be a remarkably less anti-semitic statement and much more.
>> So he does support. Okay. Wick is just totally Wick
is just totally beaten
with like a cur godamn something that someone could get on board
with than saying all globally have a responsibility for what
has happening in Israel. And you see the difference. I can say
that you know what we can recognize the actions of a majority
population that they have taken in the past that they've said
they want to do and we can hold that group specific. They've
said what do you mean they've said? Wait, what? They've said
who said? Does that statement of one Arab leader mean all Arabs
are that way? Does that what that statement of one Palestinian
leader mean all Palestinians are that way? They don't vote for
their leadership. Israelis dom
but but they haven't voted for their leadership in a long time.
Responsible for that in whatever ways they we deem appropriate.
But what we cannot do is say some Palestinian dude who lives
in Dearbornne, Michigan has anything to do with that or is responsible
for that in any way, shape or form. These are >> supported
apart South Africa. Like would just support the continuation
of a part.
>> Wait, but the argument they're using now is exactly
the argument that white South Africans use to justify a part.
The facts were different. If black No, they weren't. No, Wick.
They were tiny minority wick. They were in like 9% of the population.
There were people who fought against
specifically said that they did not want to kill all the whites,
right? They did not want to do Mandela. Nelson Mandela wasn't
the only leader. There were there were more. >> So if you
could get most Palestinians in a poll to say they don't want
to kill all Israelis, then we're good. I think we can get that
working.
>> Okay. Who are openly advocating for the killing of all
white people, the explosion of white people, and this was the
justification for for keeping apartheid in place. So you using
effectively the same argument, right, as those people who justified
aparttheid South Africa. >> It's not the same argument.
It's the fact patterns are different. And again, we have again
we have the writings and the speeches and the actions of the
people who were fighting against apartheid South Africa. They
were remarkably different than the actions of Hamas. One, >> this
guy thinks that everybody fighting against apartheid was Nelson
Mandela.
Wick ever read about Nelson Mandela's wife? Wick know anything
about Nelson Mandela's wife? Yeah, he did say farting against.
Sorry, I did miss it. Well, I I didn't say anything about it.
Could you imagine Wick's shock when he realizes who Nelson Mandela's
wife was? Nelson Mandela also did terrorism. Well, I think the
thing with terrorism from the ANC was that it was targeting buildings
and stuff, right? They try not to kill civilians because they
wanted civilians on their side. US called Nelson Mandela terrorist.
I'm sure they did.
US The US hates like that. Okay, dude. I
You think Do does anybody think Trump has the balls to say no,
the deal said Lebanon, too, and you're going to honor it?
Do you think he has the I don't think he's got the balls
was a lot more justified than the other.
>> Okay. Well, can you just can you just acknowledge that
Hamas has behaved much more atrociously than the people who opposed
South South African aparttheid that were militantly opposed to
South African aparttheid that they they never did anything on
the scale of what Hamas did. They never tried to do anything
on the scale of what Hamas did. They never acted as Hamas did.
And yes, they weren't perfect and they had some uh things that
I do condemn, right? But they these are just night and day
>> No, they're not actually. So, and I can explain why.
So, it is true that in South Africa um the the Africaners had
a long history of oppression, right? Um like the Boa worked with
like thousands of these people. the British across them and they
were a tiny minority within this this region I think like 89%
or something like this right um so they they imposed a partite
from the start said hey if we allow these these black people
that have political power they will kill us they will slaughter
us and they will push us out right and there were there was a
ton of uh violence committed by black people who were racist
and and wanted to get these these these these white South a South
African uh Africaners out um so that was that was happening it
wasn't organized in way that it is with obviously because Hamas
is like a a government a militant group that's been around for
a long time it's been armed um but I think that if there were
um groups sending money money money money money money money money money
and weapons into South Africa you absolutely would have had a
massive like a like an outburst of violence against white South
South South Africans like absolutely what and there was violence
to be clear there was like necklace happening [__]
tires people was nice and
>> these are very different situations well one you have
a quasi government organization that is calling that that has
a totalitarian control and and to be clear they abuse Palestinians
horrifically Hamas abuses Palestinians horrifically it's crazy
bad what they do to them torture them they >> so does Israel
they do actually worse than anything I've seen from Hamas like
>> why did he why He just looks so annoyed. He just looks
so angry that Duby said
Why did Why do you look so
like what isn't it embarrassing to show your bias like this?
Like you should feel so embarrassed to show your bias like this.
I just do I just want you to feel empathy FOR THE PALESTINIANS.
NO, NOT LIKE THAT. NO, NOT LIKE THAT. By pounds from what the
[__] say making that point on an ethnostate for free
slaves while being ignorant of Liberia is exemplary of his deep
ignorance on these. Well, that person's also because of course
in Nova Liberia and this was one of the three options that uh
that they tested after slavery, right? Obviously, um was it was
like it was tested out during slavery. It was either we keep
them in a slave, we keep the boot on their neck. >> Just
the fact the fact that the Somaly thing is being used to as like
a channel because dude, you're literally doing you are such a
[__] You are literally doing don't let the anti-
if you if you criticize Israel, the anti-semmites win. That's
what you're doing right now. Stop. Don't do it. >> Um so
that they don't rise up and kill us, which is I think what Israel
is currently choosing. Or we'll set them free and risk murder.
Yes, you are.
>> It's being used for a negative purpose. Actually, this
criticism is being used for a negative purpose. So, don't do
it. But it's factual. It's a factual criticism. It's a factual
point. It is factual. Go yourself. >> Many of them. I think
some of the states, if you put this in context, like a high slavery
had like 40 or 50% slave population like half the population
slaves. I just
compare Israel and Palestine to slavery in the 1860s. I think
these just are wildly not the same thing. Compare oppressed,
but they ain't slaves. If if it's all white people in the Epstein
files, I would think you should probably if you if you're looking
for leads, it's all white people. That could be a pattern. You
should investigate that pattern. Now, I don't think that's true
given the they're the
files. But hey, if you think that, let's let's let's follow that
pattern. Why >> Hold on. compared to South Africa because
they obviously
>> there are fundamental differences because the apartheid
that was in South >> I'm guessing I'm guessing there are
stronger patterns there like wealth or something but if the strongest
pattern you have is just ethnicity I don't care go ahead and
run that down >> Africa was far more oppressive the people
who are Israeli citizens um may have some rights that are different
uh may not have some rights that they probably should have I'll
agree with you there but it's it's a fundamentally >> why
you so weak about that >> thing why you say oh they may
not have because it's not as strong as the apartheid was in South
Africa it is much
I've seen the brokeest white people abuse government services.
No.
Have you seen the brokeest white people abuse the daycare system
in Minnesota?
Or is that like one group that is doing prolific like prolific
fraud in this one specific system and probably we should look
at that community and how they're joining together to commit
that fraud.
No,
that is just factually correct. You people are all stupid. any
one of you want to come on and debate this, I will crush you
because you have no idea what you're talking about. By the way,
I can totally dis I could totally agree that it's being used
for negative purposes
all over the place. Nick Shirley has no positive intent. The
GOP in Minnesota has no positive intent. That doesn't matter.
There's still fraud happening. It is the community at large perpetuating
the fraud.
The Somali
Obviously, this implies that you think maybe they shouldn't have
these rights. So, if you do think they should have those rights,
but They probably should think it's the same, right? Do you think
it's the same that if someone cuts you off in traffic versus
someone blowing >> Yes. The Somali fraud case in America
doesn't reflect on Somali people. It is not inherent in the Somali
DNA or somehow in American Somali immigrants that they're somehow
evil and they commit fraud all the time. There is a specific
community of people where a pattern of behavior, a pattern of
criminal behavior is unfolding. This is like saying, "Hey, you're
looking into the mafia. It would be really racist for you to
focus on Italians in like the '7s, maybe 1910s or something.
Yeah, you're obviously stupid. You're obviously saying something.
It is literally ethnic. It's kept within ethnic lines because
people feel solidarity along those lines. People feel solidarity
in that community and they aren't going to rat on each other.
Holy [__]
Up your car. These are both things that I don't want to happen
to me, but if I had if I had to rate them on absolutely just
no brains participate in this argument. You guys are lost. scale.
Getting cut off in traffic while bad is far far less bad than
having my car blown up for whatever reason.
>> No, I think you're minimizing uh the horrors the Palestinians
have to deal with in Israel. Right. >> Hold on. You're
groped up, son. Disagree with what I just said about the Italian
mafia. The literal Italian mafia. That is the situation. You
have a criminal ring happening in a city. It's happening one
specific case. It is not weird if you're investigating that kind
of fraud to start with that community. You have a bunch of evidence
of it being super pervasive in that community. I'm saying something
that is obviously true and people are disagreeing with it. That's
why I'm getting annoyed, Missy. That's what I'm talking about
specifically. >> No, wait. To be clear, if you think that
what's happen what's been happening in Gaz for decades now is
not comparable or is not as bad or worse actually than what's
happening in South South African part. You're just >> You
brought up the Italian mafia when I'm just saying bringing up
race to justify an entire crime pattern is why do you think I'm
saying that? I literally said multiple times I don't think it's
inherent Somali DNA to like steal from the government. Are you
I didn't say that ever. I said it's prolific in that community.
It's not weird for you to run down leads in that community when
investigating that specific type of fraud. And then you lost
your mind because you're
>> you're crazy. You're just not right up enough. You need
to do not informed about research. >> You understand that
first? Well, do you think it was as bad as uh antibellum or Yeah.
Like 1800 slavery in America? >> No, but you >> Yeah,
but why does the Somali thing have relation to fraud? because
the fraud is being perpetuated by the Somali community. It is
all of the clients are Somali immigrants. All of the perpetrators
are Somali immigrants. It is a crime ring that is contained within
this community. There may be other people doing that kind of
fraud outside of that community, but they are negligible in relation
to the Somali group doing fraud in that specific program in that
specific community.
And so focusing on other stuff instead of running down that community,
figure out why this ring exists and how it exists and what they're
doing. Probably not as important, probably not as useful, not
as good like a use of your time at all.
If you turn an informant in that community, they will give you
information on everybody in that community. It is literally just
more efficient. You'd be stupid to think otherwise, but there
it is.
>> Ethic
something else is worth holocaust. Also not Holocaust, but that
doesn't mean that it isn't an ethnic hierarchy that should be
called out. And if I were to talk about the [__]
antel himself, I wouldn't say, "Oh, maybe these Africans have
don't have some rights." They probably should have. I say they
absolutely should have these rights. And it's [__]
racist and a unacceptable. Not give them these rights. But when
you talk about Israel, you soften your language. You say, "Oh,
maybe they shouldn't have these right or maybe they probably
should have these rights." Well, there shouldn't be question.
Why is there a question? >> You're getting destroyed. I'll
read you the stats. Like you can >> You're getting destroyed.
Don't get distracted. 74% of people thought you were distracting.
I don't give A YOU'RE GETTING DESTROYED. 74 74% of people in
my chat thought you were stupid, man.
No way. I can't Oh, I can't believe that with Destiny watching
the stream live, I can't believe 74% of people in the chat thought
thought Doobie was stupid. >> That's crazy.
That's insane.
Wow. Most stupid, right? You don't give a But that's okay. That's
just what the stats say, though. Polls say for whatever reason
you give a about stats when 90% of Jews
>> uh does dub. Guys, the question that I have is, does
Doobie really believe this? Do you guys think Dubbie really believes
this? I'm sorry. I'm going to play the clip again. So, unlucky
for you if you've uh already watched it. Just in case you guys
missed this earlier any of this or is he just doing for the love
of the game for everybody that is on this
queen Perry Chud logic doobie like on that team all of them have
100% thrown their hat in basically with like the Hassan political
belief system. So whatever Hassan says >> Oh man I thought
this was 27 earlier it's 80. >> We've thrown our hat in
with the Hassan political system. Okay. So whatever Hassan says,
these people will carry that as far as they possibly can. So
we have to carry it as far as we possibly can.
I called this cringe like three times tonight. You guys see the
car heart? Hold on. You got you guys weren't here. I got to remember
sometimes that like some people weren't here when the stream
started. I'm not sure that everybody seen Hassan wearing this
dumbass car jacket over his suit. Okay,
you want to talk about snarking? Let's start this right here.
What is this outfit?
Brown over gray. Hey yo,
this guy's doing a holocaust on fashion.
dude, Vasho pacing this guy in multiple ways. Okay. Jesus. Sorry,
I got to pull it back just a little bit.
People will carry that as far as they possibly can. So whatever
Hassan's beliefs are on this, obviously Hassan doesn't think
anti-semitism is a real thing unless it comes from white nationalists
or whatever else they're going to believe. So Dubie will have
to take whatever that position is along with the rest of them
in this community isn't just right-wing. He is he was that's
where he came from. But now they all pretend to be communists
or lefties or whatever because they they all have to write Hosan.
It's so it's so
It's just so incoherent. They're like trying to take all the
things that they've been told and make it make sense somehow.
And it's just totally incoherent.
It's very funny,
dude. He's like building up this whole web of lies and he like
he can't even follow it himself anymore. I don't know if Destiny
truly believes this. Probably not. No, he doesn't. It's just
it's the same thing over and over again, right? It's this guy.
It's uh it's this
the communist Kiwi farmer, right-wing agog skitso Hassan le cabal
is doing it to us again, GUYS. IT'S ALL OF THEM TOGETHER. THEY'RE
ALL doing it. It's Chad Logic. It's Assad. It's Vosch. It's everybody.
It's everybody.
10 hours. >> Did you said Arabs in this region? So in this
region have ethnically cleansed people, genocid people tortured
people. >> Yes, that would be okay to say because it's
true. But the difference
you and this article Well, I'll say this article, this article
is saying that all Jews, right, everywhere globally, that's the
difference.
You just are pretending not to understand. >> No, I'm pretending.
I've gone over I've gone over that for you like over and over
specifically. You've glossed over. You haven't.
You've been shown to be a >> He literally Wick has literally
just
not listened.
>> What about people outside the country? But do they support
broadly and is the like 90 to 95%. Do they support the country?
Why are you bringing UP STATS? YOU LOVE STATS, don't you?
>> Yeah. Great engagement, buddy. You've been shown that
you never accept this in other situations. You accept people
situations. No. Now you're just lying. >> I'm not lying.
We did it with Palestinians. Would it be okay? I'll just ask
you. Would you consider it bigoted for me to go to a university
in America or a campus to find a Palestinian person who
>> do you have proof that 90% of Palestinians support Hamas
in the way that most people support the IDF in
you have any reason to believe that that is the case wick
also little thing again there is this
that people do and I I don't know I maybe I should come up with
a way to explain this in a punchy way but it is the idea of upholding
the status quo you're going to constantly argue for like well
is it okay to do this is it okay to do that when it's when things
are tilted when like the ship is sinking it's like dude we have
to start getting the lifeboats we have to start taking action
that fixes things Okay, we have to start taking action that fixes
things. And they go, well, are you sure about that? Can we really
do that? Are you sure about this? Are you sure about that?
They do this dance, try to distract you. It's like, bro, time
is of the essence right now. Stuff needs to get fixed. Stuff
needs to happen.
>> No connection to Hezbollah or anything like that, and
hold them responsible and uh for for uh for the actions of Hamas.
You would obviously call that bigoted. >> Wait, do you
remember me bringing up uh Germans after World War II? Catholics,
white people, men, Muslims. Do you remember all those examples
I brought up of me saying this exact kind of thing? >> Wait,
hold on. Yes, actually. Wick. Yes. For Palestinian, answer my
question, >> Wick, answer my question. You can just answer
my question. Would it be bigoted? >> I just again, you
could say it's bigoted. It's just that what percentage of people
are Zionists?
>> Okay. Which percentage of people support
I I would even say like if you wanted, you know, if people were
protesting Israel and you asked them like, do you disavow the
attacks on civilians?
I think it's reasonable to expect an answer back on that, right?
Don't you don't you disavow the killing of civilians? Yeah.
Do you?
Whoa. That's a little anti-Semitic. I'm listening to go
Michigan to campus or anywhere in this. Find a Palestinian guy
who has no connection. Why do you start losing like
>> Hey, you are responsible and should be held responsible
for the actions of Hamas. You would call that >> extremely
transparent. So when you're losing an argument, you start talking
over people. trying to address I'm trying to address it right
now actually but I needed you to stop interrupting me right if
we need to bring in like lactose into moderate that'd be totally
fine but you got to stop interrupting me when I'm trying to answer
your question right so the reason I brought up all those other
examples like was to show you that I'm not applying a double
standard I'm applying the same standard which is the same standard
that she's applying which is Catholics uh Muslims
uh men
etc all these groups have some responsibility to call out uh
toxic behavior within their own community 100% and again uh in
intercomun criticism is totally normal totally >> oh the
all men thing is also O a good example of this, right? How do
you fix like a culture where violence against women is is mostly
downplayed without saying, "Hey men, we need to do better without
having people in that community that could easily isolate people,
especially in times where women didn't have s women didn't have
the right to vote, right?" Well, obviously men have to police
other men in that case, right? Within that community. No, it's
not calling all men. It's saying, "Hey, there's like a problem
here that we should all acknowledge and try to do better. We're
participating in a system that is causing problems. It's all
of our responsibility to go, hey, this is like probably bad.
We should probably not do this, right? How many times have I
heard people be asked to condemn Hamas? The title is an illusion
to that, right? The the title to this, yes, all Jews. No, that
this is a response to people going, "Well, it's not all Jews."
When when people are like criticizing Israel and they conflate
Israel and Zionism or sorry, they conflate Zionism and Judaism,
people go, "Not all support Israel, man. and certainly not all
support the actions of Israel right now.
And she's saying, "Yeah, but you kind of do."
Yeah, but you kind of all do. Okay. Gillette commercial. Not
like the Gillette commercial.
Not quite like that. But it's like, listen, I don't even think
it has to doesn't have to be like overt or like cringe. Like
this is just this is the this is the version of the Gillette
commercial. Okay. It's like a little too over the top. It's a
little too performative and it starts to it waters waters down
the message a little bit. Now, unfortunately,
you know, Palestinians are dying and maybe I understand the hyperbole
here a little bit more. Okay. Anyway,
>> accepted I accept all that, but you keep saying that
I that I'm only okay with it for and this is a lie because I
said to you repeatedly. >> I want it to be clear you liar
that you didn't answer my question. I got >> Okay, you
your question's your question. I'm I'm So you can ask me a yes
or no question, but you're using it disingenuously. So now when
you do your disingenuous framing, I have to point out how it's
disingenuous, how it's disanalogous, how it doesn't capture the
essence of the question. >> Normal, totally accepted. I
accept all that. But you keep saying that I that I'm only okay
with it for this is a lie. Cuz I said to you repeatedly, >> I
want it to be clear, you liar, that you didn't answer my question.
I asked you a specific question and you obuscated. You went on
this rant that wasn't connected. You didn't answer my answer.
No question, Doobie. You are a liar. You're just a liar. You
can go away now. Bye. I asked you a very specific question. I
interrupted you because you weren't answering that question.
You continued to assure me that you were about to answer that
question and then you lied to my face. Get the out of here. Get
the out.
I've never Does
Does Wick have like anything else he gets this fired up about?
I've never seen Wick this fired up about anything except anti-semitism.
How do they do it? How do they program the cattle this well?
I don't get it. I literally don't get it. He's so insanely mad.
And I've never seen him this mad in any other case. Get the out.
Go take Jew somewhere else.
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ. That's insanity. I don't understand
why anyone takes us seriously. And he wonders why no one believes
him. >> It's Doobie. He's the frog. People only take him
as seriously as like his arguments go. He's like the frog. He's
like the goofy ass frog who who will steal man arguments he doesn't
even necessarily like care to or or doesn't necessarily like
ideologically believe himself. He's like the frog. What do you
mean take him ser? Bro, you just you just kicked a three-dimensional
frog out of your Discord and went, "How does anybody take this
guy seriously?"
Bro, he's a cartoon frog. What the I'm a cartoon penguin.
Yeah, is doing this quite seriously and nobody takes him seriously.
>> You told me that you were about to answer that question.
Is it connected? You didn't answer my Now. Bye. I asked you a
very specific question. I interrupted you because you weren't
answering that question. You continued to assure me that you
were about to answer that question and then you lied to my face.
Get the out of here. Get the
Get the out. Go hat you somewhere else.
Jesus Christ.
kind of shocking. I can't believe that somebody who is this offended
by anti-semitism also takes the Lord's name in vain. Can't make
it up. >> Jesus Christ. That's insane. Insanity. >> Jeez,
man. >> What the I don't understand why anyone takes this
seriously. And he wonders why no one believes him when he accuses
other people of doing things, right? He wonders why his campaign
of terror against other groups and other streamers and other
people, right, just don't work. It's because he >> Dude,
this is embarrassing. No way. No
Oh my god.
What is Dude, this is
this is a level of like um this is a level of total
that I've never seen before. Campaign of Terror. This is all
Wick doing his little minstrel show for DJers so that he can
get money. That's it. That's literally it. He's literally going,
"Doobie makes everything up about Destiny. Nobody believes you,
DUBY. YOU'RE YOU'RE LYING. YOU'RE A LIAR." WE GOT to watch it
again.
>> I don't understand why anyone takes this seriously.
And he wonders why no one believes him when he accuses other
people of doing things, right? He wonders why his campaign of
terror >> pretty much everybody with any amount of sanity
in your Discord believes all of the things about Destiny. Uh
the only thing maybe they don't believe about him is the what
like he they might believe he got catfished now. They do believe
he had they do believe he leaked all these uh he sent all of
these videos without the people's consent. It's like and there's
one thing that he also misunderstood by the way. He didn't know
that he wasn't talking to that girl. Right? So we all found that
out at the same time. By the way, there's reasons to doubt that
story. I I'd say you probably can't go against the testimony,
but there's reasons to doubt that story that she didn't participate
at all. Anyway, is it very funny that like what do you think
Dubbie is lying about?
What does Wick think Doobie is lying about? I actually don't
know.
Very goofy >> against other groups and other streamers
and other people, right? Just don't work. It's because he's a
liar. No one trusts him. His credibility is shut. Incoming obsession.
Oh, Wick is Wick is
POV.
Total total
just to death. I can't even I can't even, dude. He's He's crushed.
It's over. It's never been this
Somebody get the Mr. girl impression and Wick gets to be the
child this time. Okay, very up. >> Let me continue to read
the super chats.
from gelatinous rub
populations acting this way. It's not something Wick applies
to any other group, not even the same people in Europe, only
when they're near Israel. That's not true.
That's literally true. You are actually literally racist to
The exact lines you were drawing for every other group you totally
threw away and said Arabs are going to attack Israel. If they
THEY CAN'T LET THE PALESTINIANS IN, they'll try to kill all the
Arabs.
What happened the last time they let them in? They killed all
the Sorry, did I say kill all the Arabs? Kill all the
like I said >> that's not true at all. What other populations
act this way? Like so for example, I can make predictions of
what would happen if MAGA got into power and I did, right? A
group of people who share an
that's an ideology. It's opt-in. That's the argument you made
earlier. It's not an ethnic. It's not deterministic. Right. That's
an ideology. It's opt in idiot. You literally made this argument.
You yourself in his own in this conversation. You
he literally argued against you. But he's like, "No, no, no.
This is you." When I talk about mocka people, that's an ideology.
And now he's trying to use
He's trying to use it now. The thing he disagreed with Dubie
on, he's trying to use it now.
Ideology. I predicted. Hm. This is what they are going to do.
But that is a very different thing than holding.
>> Oh, donation's going to roll in now. The principled
liberal who supports ethnostates and can't stop lying about what
I said repeatedly is the one with credibility. Lauo,
>> everyone who happened to vote for Trump responsible
for what Trump has done. I don't hold that position. I fought
against that position when I fought against Destiny on this.
That's just true. Uh $5 from trip one. You can be bigoted towards
your own community. You can also be wrong if you give a take
about your own community. Use your brain doobie. Use good think
$2 from Detroit one. What is Duby's wanted solution? Yes, all
or and then Lawson Harrison for $10. Dubers, did you know the
case slur isn't actually a slur and in fact a political term.
The soldiers of Odin put out a great article you should check
out. I don't even know what the soldiers of Odin is. Sounds
>> soldiers of Odin. That's definitely some white supremacist.
Jeb Tan is here. There's like this group of people like Jeb Tan,
Lactoid,
and Doobie. And I think there's one other guy that's in that
group of people who are like the debaters who just like debating.
Maybe Doobie. Wait, Doobie, Lactoy, Jeb Tan. There's one other
guy I'm not thinking of that goes with this group
and they're like all they just debate a lot
and
you can just tell they all can see what's going on because they'll
all actually like argue it.
It's just very funny. Um, but I I'm guessing he'll be on uh on
Dubby's side here. Very funny. >> Soraumnet
five Wick TVF sub memberships. Thank you for that. I am just
very frustrated, gang. If you want to answer my question, you're
free to answer my question, but don't tell me you're going to
answer my question and then not answer my question. Just don't
do that. >> 15 gifted memberships after screaming about
how Destiny was actually innocent all along. Very cool. Very
awesome how that goes, right? Um, I'm not gonna ban you, Duby.